[Musique]
cette usine a été construite parce que
nous étions saisi de nombreuses demandes
d'adhésion de la part des producteurs du
nord de la charente et tout
particulièrement notamment de la
laiterie d'aunac la laiterie coopérative
d'aunac qui demandait sa fusion avec
saint save your à partir du déversement
du lait aucune manipulation humaine
jusqu'à la sortie du beurre seuls quatre
ouvriers surveille la bonne marche du
matériel entièrement automatique
en fait chaque équipe de quatre hommes
veillent à la fabrication de quelque 10
tonnes de beurre
[Musique]
nous sommes 100 personnes seulement
actuellement et ce qu'il faut préciser
c'est que tout ce personnel est
mensualisé et que notre souci le souci
constant de la direction générale et
surtout de donner le plein emploi de
l'amader une partie de ce personnel
procès de ramiz son carton des beurre
préalablement pacte est toujours sans
aucune manipulation
la plus grande partie du personnel
spécialisé est employée elle à la
fabrication des fromages la l'artisanat
demeure en grande partie ne serait ce
que pour conserver cette saveur qui a
fait le renom des fromages de france
mais voyons avec les frères chastenay
comment se fabriquent les fromages de
sinsat violent et comment s'opère la
gestion d'une entreprise moderne
[Musique]
monsieur les ja chastanet vous êtes dit
ans l'un des premiers amateurs de leur
chef d'europe
oui mais je pense que c'est une
réputation qui n'est pas usurpée nous
sommes une usine qui travaillent le lait
de chèvre depuis très très longtemps et
pour ne citer que trois chiffres
et pour ne pas remonter trop loin 1948
production un million de litres de lait
1960 deux millions de litres de lait
1970 6 millions de litres de lait ce qui
laisse espérer encore pour les années à
venir
encore beaucoup de travail alors le
fabrication des fromages de chèvre est
resté un stade quand même artisanale
c'est obligatoire sont d'autres oui je
pense que tout ce qui traite à la
fromagerie d'une manière générale un
avantage pour le consommateur c'est de
toujours rester autant que faire se
pisse le plus près possible des
fabrications artisanales
malheureusement dû sur le plan
industriel on est obligé malheureusement
de d'évoluer du fait de la production de
très très très inégale en cours d'année
qui passent dix ans de 40 mille litres
de lait par jour la pointe c'est-à-dire
au mois de juin à 3000 litres de lait
par jour au mois de février
c'est impératif donc de production très
différenciée nous on nous amène à
industrialiser pour limiter au maximum
le le travail d'une part à la pointe et
pour éviter dans les creux de saison
d'avoir un personnel par trop important
il n'occupait du fait du manque de
production et du manque de matières
premières mais vous avez une façon
particulière de faire écouter vos
cahiers la façon particulière chaque
fromagerie digne de ce nom on essaie
toujours d'avoir un petit tour de main
supérieure à ses collègues et
concurrents bien sûr chez nous c'est le
cas nous
en sont à voir certes un tour de main
nous écoutons le fromage d'une manière
un peu particulière de façon à essayer
de conserver au maximum
malgré tout les l'industrialisation de
la fabrication le petit tour de marquise
annales pour conserver tout son parfum
tout scénario formage de chef qu'il
mérite bien la direction d'une
importante les prix moderne doit poser
des problèmes de gestion
évidemment les problèmes de gestion sont
le souci majeur d'une entreprise et plus
l'importance s'accroît comme celle
passant savio le plus il faut se
rapprocher au jour le jour du suivi de
la comptabilité
il n'aurait pas était important d'avoir
fait une usine moderne
si on n'avait pas également eu les
moyens de travailler d'une façon moderne
avec des outils appropriés
c'est ce que nous avons essayé de
réaliser en plusieurs temps parce que la
mise en place de tous les programmes ne
peut se réaliser évidemment du jour au
lendemain on commençait par la paye de
lait qui est d'ailleurs en cours à
l'heure actuelle et nous avons intégré
progressivement sur un an l'ensemble de
la gestion de l'entreprise en utilisant
les modernisations du plan comptable et
les chiffres jusqu'au numéro 5
ce qui nous permet d'avoir avec les du
crédit agricole et du perforateur de
bande des renseignements et des données
qui ne sont renvoyées par le crédit
agricole avec lequel nous avons établi
des liaisons très étroits de
collaboration
un laboratoire à l'image de cette usine
permet un contrôle permanent de la
qualité délais en provenance des fermes
de la région mais un concept de plus en
plus de fromage de chèvre pourquoi à
votre avis je pense que c'était un petit
retour aux sources en ce sens que il y à
bien longtemps les gens consomment
énormément de fromage de chèvre c'était
en ce qui concerne l'animal la chèvre
lavage du pauvre et je crois que j'ai de
très nombreux centenaires du fait de la
grande consommation des fromages de
chèvre de l'époque
peut-être maintenant c'est un retour à
cette sagesse d'antan et chaque jour il
faut aller collecter le lait après
nettoyage les camions citernes par à
nouveau vers les lieux de ramassage
[Musique]